hey guys we see here with a quick
gamespot news update for you NIS America
have announced a slew of new titles that
they're going to be releasing in the
west and who knows what they are disgaea
one of them's disgaea I'm so sorry the
titles include disgaea five alliance of
vengeance which will be released
exclusively for the PlayStation 4 as
well as danganronpa another episode
Ultra despair girls for the PlayStation
Vita and Rodia the sky soldier for the
Wii U and 3ds role-playing game disgaea
five alliance of vengeance will
introduce a new alliance attacks feature
to the series the system will be
available two main characters when their
relationships are appropriately aligned
the recruitment feature makes a return
from previous games offering over 40
races and jobs as options developed by
nippon ichi software disgaea five
alliance of vengeance will be released
in fall of this year meanwhile
danganronpa fans will be pleased to
learn the danganronpa another episode
ultra despair girls will be getting a
Western release the game takes place
between the events of danganronpa
trigger happy havoc and danganronpa to
goodbye despair in it players must shoot
their way through action sequences and
solve various riddles and puzzles to
escape a city infested with strange
teddy bears known as mono kuma's kimaru
from the first danganronpa game will
return to star in another episode the
game will be released for the
PlayStation Vita this fall NIS America
also confirmed the new IP Rodia the sky
soldier will be launching for the Wii U
and 3ds this year the action game will
bring speed and adventure together in a
new journey through the sky are you
excited for more danganronpa and disgaea
am i even pronouncing those correctly
and we know in the comment section below
for all the latest make sure you stay
tuned to gamespot com
you